back now at 7 30 on CBS mornings we've
got a live look at the Capitol because
the midterms are coming up and they're
coming up fast but there has been a
recent shift on where the voters stand
on some key issues including how the
president is handling the economy to
break down the latest CBS News
Battleground tracker John has CBS News
elections and Survey director Anthony
salvato with him John take it away thank
you Tony Anthony it's good to be with
you physically in person the latest
Battleground tracker you have a change
in the storyline from July explain that
change to us yeah back in July John
after talking to voters in all these
congressional districts we were seeing
Republicans with a lead to take control
of the house you need 218 they were at 2
30 but in our latest estimate again
talking to voters in all these districts
Republicans go down to 226 so a little
bit of momentum there for the Democrats
back the other way and where is that
coming from and I'll double load this
question which is last week we had
primary races and and a special election
which abortion favorite was a very
important issue is that coming up in
what you're seeing yeah and in those
races the Democrats overperformed their
numbers from the past and look at this
in the poll likely voters are more
likely to say they're going to the polls
to support abortion rights than to
oppose them and that is accruing to the
Democrats that's number one and then the
other big part of this John I'll show
you is that Democrats are making some
gains among key groups including among
Women Voters including among Women
Voters they have risen in support with
including white women with college
degrees up from 45 to 54. so it's not
only it's a motivating issue for them
it's not just their they have an opinion
about abortion it's actually changing
the way they believe about this election
Democrats now say it's the most
important thing now let's talk about the
Republicans since you and I has talked
Donald Trump has had a visit from the
FBI to Mar-A-Lago how is that showing up
in your numbers yeah there's a couple of
things here one is that Republicans say
they want the party to support Donald
Trump on this that's important
politically because it a motivates their
base to turn out but B puts pressure on
those Party leaders not to criticize him
right and maybe even to speak up for him
to to come out and positively have to
say something in defense of him indeed
but for the rest of the electorate
Donald Trump is a net negative and if
you look at where he's a factor and by
the way he is a factor for most people
which is unusual for midterms the former
president right but there's more people
out there to oppose him than support him
so this is Republicans being motivated
but for Independence and Democrats it's
against him all right so now let's step
back out this election is taking place
in the context of a very jittery wobbly
economy what do your numbers show about
what people think about the economy and
or the president's handling of it
getting a little better on the economy
we've got some movement now it's still
bad let's emphasize that and by the way
Republicans are winning people who say
that the economy is bad and important
that's important as well but a little
bit of improvement so an uptick in Biden
approval and that in turn motivates
Democrats who say that they're more
likely to vote vote this year all right
Anthony salvanto thank you as always for
going through all those numbers Gail
back to you all right we'll be watching
the numbers a lot lately